this is ingram angle from a busy
washington tonight we're going to start
right off with the lies of the left that
is the focus of tonight's angle
all right here's an angle rule of thumb
whenever a democrat in an election year
claims to be a sensible moderate or
claims that he's going to challenge his
party's orthodoxy he's lying
national review's headline today made me
howl
moderate democrats come out against
biden's out of touch student loan
forgiveness they go on to quote ohio
democrat and senate candidate tim ryan
who claimed yesterday that the biden
debt cancellation sends the wrong
message to the millions of ohioans
without a degree working just as hard to
make ends meet
now ryan thinks voters are really stupid
he voted with pelosi and biden 100 of
the time this congress
yeah
and yet now because he's running against
a real populist and jd vance he's tried
to morph into being one himself
it's all lies the truth is if he's
elected ryan just like all the other
pretend moderates out there will be
another sure vote for the biden agenda
and biden's daughtering demeanor is so
bad these days that democrats who are up
for re-election are saying thanks but no
thanks joe to any personal appearances
by the leader of their own party if you
can believe it
mark kelly in arizona couldn't bring
himself to tell the truth when asked
about biden joining him on the campaign
trail i'll welcome anybody to come to
arizona you know travel around the state
at any time as long as i'm here you know
if i'm not up in in washington in
session and and talk about what arizona
needs
of course that's a lie
he and most every other democrat running
in a competitive race wants biden and
his 41.5 approval rating nowhere nearby
now the other lie is that somehow biden
has like what turned the corner right he
has joe mentum
he has renewed focus and he really has
the wind at his back
really
they want a national ban they want to
pass a legislative national ban in the
congress if the mag of republicans win
control of the congress
it won't matter where you live
women won't have the right to choose
anywhere we'll codify roe v wade
[Applause]
this really is all biden the democrats
have to run on they don't have a plan to
raise your standard of living or to
tackle the fentanyl surge at the border
no no no
but they have a plan to facilitate more
abortions in the united states
they don't intend to save you from
inflation or the cartels but from
republicans in places like mississippi
and oklahoma who want to protect the
unborn
look they can't run on their real agenda
banning gas-powered cars banning beef
open borders of course the sexual
indoctrination of kids
so they're running on the abortion lie
it's all poor beto has in texas
women all across texas are no longer
free to make decisions about our own
body
no longer free to choose if a pregnancy
is right for us or our families
and women will die because of it all
because of greg abbott's abortion law
it's too extreme
uh first of all i wouldn't have used the
heartbeat background you know sound
effect i think that didn't work
they need something anything to grab
onto to avoid being swept away in a red
wave
so no surprise that they're attributing
their win in one special election to
abortion as well and suddenly
the results in new york's 19th district
where pat ryan beat mark molinaro
have overwhelming significance
he made abortion rights a central focus
of his campaign this was a big test for
democrats who are hoping that this
becomes a driving issue and mobilizes
voters in november they're seeing that
abortion is a good ineffective for them
argument
against the attacks on the economy
supreme court nuking abortion rights has
shifted the midterm momentum to the
democrats
now it's either a lie or wishful
thinking because the truth is the
outcome here turned on a single county
and guess who was executive for that
county
yeah the county executive was pat ryan
in fact democrats have been pointing to
the four special elections that swung
their way since the dobbs decision as
proof positive that abortion will lead
them to the electoral promised land
but as dave wasserman of cook political
notes those four districts have
something in common
dem successes in these specials have
been fueled by high engagement in
college heavy enclaves like lincoln
nebraska rochester minnesota ulster
county new york and ithaca new york
pocket's not all that representative of
the larger fall electorate
not to mention that in poll after poll
voters have signaled that their number
one concern is the economy and oh wait
where does abortion fall according to
pew it's the eighth most important
priority behind things like education
safety and supreme court appointments
but you got to hand it to the democrats
i think that because as republicans in
leadership they gripe about the quality
of our candidates democrats no matter
how bad things look no matter how dismal
they are politically they just put on a
happy face
we're happy i it feel it feels it feels
feels good feels good we had this sort
of season of shame where you know
democrats are just so disappointed and
frustrated what's going on in d.c
dismayed by the republicans we've gone
from disappointed determined now because
biden is winning
if he's not lying he's delusional
for biden to be winning he would need to
be improving the lives of the people
he's supposed to be serving the american
people
but how are the american people feeling
about things under biden
well a majority is saying that america's
best days are behind her
74 say the country's on the wrong track
if that level of pessimism qualifies as
winning i'd hate to see what losing
looks like under biden
but when polls begin to tighten as is
already happening in pennsylvania i'm
telling you democrats prepare for this
they are going to look even more
desperate become even more desperate
beyond abortion and their professed
belief that biden's agenda is actually
popular
their other go-to lie is the smear of
millions of their fellow americans
the radical governor of new york kathy
hokel doesn't want to debate republicans
on the issues she only wants to demonize
them
we're fighting to bring government back
to the people
and out of the hands of dictators
and we're here to say
that the era
of trump
and zeldin and molinaro just jump on a
bus and head down to florida where you
belong you don't represent our values
you are not new yorkers
not new yorkers think about that for a
moment this from a woman who treats
illegals as full-fledged citizens but
now tax-paying residents
who disagree with her politically
they actually don't even have the right
to live in this state
she actually believes that by the way
but luckily for the gop there's a
governor who knows how to flip the
script on the true dictators
we protected people's freedoms jobs
businesses we made sure kids could be in
in school and we liberated
22 million floridians from local
mandates and restrictions we protected
them against vax mandates i think the
people
that are dictatorial are the ones that
want to lock you down
bingo the same people who are fine with
shuttering schools devastating education
and the mental health of our young
people fine with forcing police and
nurses off the job for idiotic vaccine
mandates
are now calling republicans extreme
voters are excited to defeat these
extreme republicans who are running for
congress do you feel like republicans
have sort of misread the landscape
because i mean they're still talking
about
crime and inflation they are misreading
the landscape and democrats are doing
something that joy that we don't always
do well which is we are defining the
republicans for their extremism
you're getting the theme here
but you know what is extreme
robbing children especially
disadvantaged children and minorities of
the opportunity to go to school all
because their parents refuse to get them
a coveted shot they don't want and they
don't need that's dictatorial
and this is precisely what the venal and
heartless mayor of dc where we are right
tonight muriel bowser is mandating not
only is she blocking any students who
are unvaccinated from attending school
she won't even let them learn virtually
because apparently you can get covered
from the zoom
so for more than 40 percent of black
students who are unvaccinated
no education for you
you want to talk about jim crow that's
jim crow it's not just extreme it's
vindictive and i bet
i bet she has a hate has no home here
yard sign in front of her residents to
boot
rewarding the elites fighting to kill
the unborn and the demonization of your
fellow americans that is one hell of a
national strategy
so i say keep it up democrats
keep telling yourself those lies
and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else